[Musique]
bonjour ce céline dont se retrouvent
aujourd'hui pour faire une recette du
bois et du poitou avec des bons produits
du terroir du pote donc 250 g de farine
100 g de sucre en poudre 125 ans de
beurre 1 oeuf et 5 grammes de sel et on
va utiliser un jaune d'oeuf laboureur
donc pour faire un mois y est c'est très
facile reprend un saladier on va mettre
notre famille
la bonne femme du poète 100 g de sucre
en poudre 125 g de beurre un peu de sel
et on va ajouter notre offre donc après
on va pétrir donc pour pc on prend la
farine du bout des doigts
néron pousse vers le milieu voilà et on
va appuyer avec la paume de la main
mais voilà ces petits gestes
[Musique]
copé sur cinq bonnes minutes jusqu'à ce
qu'ils aient plus de farine au fond du
saladier et qu'on est une boule bien
homogène la voix obtenir une boule comme
ça bien lisse bien ferme des stages tout
seul but salade et donc après une fois
qu'on a obtenu une bouillabaisse comme
ça on prend une plaque qui va au four
une taxe recouverte d'un papier
sulfurisé pourquoi de sa tâche on doit
prendre un cercle qui vous avez pas dire
que vous pouvez faire sentir qu'on fait
un rouge nous verrons ensuite on va
mettre la far et le le nom de pat et on
va aplatir comme ça avec la paume de la
main pour faire le lot nous voilà bien
avec la formula maintenant ça fait
travailler les mains et les poignets les
muscles donc une fois qu'on a bien
étaler la pâte toute façon de
d'épaisseur très régulière dans le
cercle on veut c est avec tes doigts
on va faire des pizzas encore ça voilà
une tondeuse broyé par la petite école
on tourne une autre feuille de papier
sulfurisé et on les doit
vous mettez bien de ma gauche sur la
pâte au port et vous enfoncez recevoir
ensuite on va prendre un jaune d'oeuf
avec un pinceau à bien mélanger
et là on va doré avec le pinceau
délicatement ensuite dernière étape
on croit une fourchette comprend pas
pousser les jaunes d'oeuf
mais on fait des petits traits un peu
des parallèles avec une fourchette
rob moore ensuite dans notre sens voilà
une zone éloignée du poitou ensuite on
m'a l'enfourner 180° pendant 10 15
minutes
mais à surveiller selon les fours
et voici un joli broyé du poitou bien
rayé bien dorée une petite consignes
pour ceux qui ne savent pas de broyé du
poitou la tradition si on ne le kopa on
le casse avec un grand point milieu donc
pour les plus téméraires d'entre vous
pouvez essayer moi on va essayer mais je
peux sur les arrivées 1
attention c'est parti on y va 1 2 3 2 3
et voilà un bon foyer du poitou est
maintenant un petit café ou un petit thé
et c'est un délice
je vois la pythie on se retrouve bientôt
pour une nouvelle recette du poitou
[Musique]